[Musique]
agathe et kelly vous avez été jetés à
les à côtés de kelly pour regardant pour
l'instant vous rester là agathe et kelly
vous étiez parti on vous a fait croire
que vous aviez faire une soirée un gala
la parité riela et ce gars là ne s'est
pas passé comme prévu
regardez c'est parti sai baba normal
activity on est en direct ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
ouais
merci j'avais bien et donc vous
travaillez pour l'émission télé c'est
simple c'est l'émission sympa sans
connaître reviens moi ça comme ça c'est
fait je voulais capitanat je croyais
bien faire franchement là le chemin on
va maintenant là où on va le monde
mais où va notre [ __ ] de sociétés
belges au pire on a fort bas loin
monsieur un peu de route est
effectivement pas d'accord
[Musique]
ça risque de prendre un tout petit peu
plus de temps soit ils ont fermé la n104
bien on est parti
[Musique]
c'est un psychopathe je suis très choqué
non a priori juste je conduis fait mon
métier
nous approchons
mettons ce site du coup sûr le château
[Musique]
mais pour le moment
c'est qu'on trouve à réfléchir sans
stress
non
dans mais quelle angoisse
oh mon dieu mais je suis pas encadré 1 /
h plus son sillage en
je fais pipi dans ma culotte et
immédiatement
mais c'est des chemins quand même pas
d'eau mills a séparé
vous voulez un trottoir
comme prévu dominique amyot s'est hissé
jusqu'à 15 sur le bord de la route
[Applaudissements]
poule
on va pas les laisser
juste
ça va madame mizen mais pas du tout je
suis actuellement par mm
il faut jeanneret dollars
je la dépose un peu plus loin et même si
je crois qu'à un village juste après
l'étrange à des poses juste après et
donc vous allez où exactement ce que
j'écris tout droit
si vous regarder devant vous s'il vous
plaît
tous droits ok j'ai compris qu'on allait
tout droit jusqu'au tout droit jusqu où
droit de toute façon nous on est là on a
cinq
inquiétez pas je prends à gauche je
dépose et
mouille-toi des mojitos avait l'air
froid je le craignais qu'est ce que vous
voulez un téléphone mais c'est même pas
parlé fornella l'hôpital je pense
qu'elle comprend 24 salles à pied nous
rien c'est un jeu je sais pas c'est quoi
ça je sais pas regarder ça ça marche pas
mais là y'a bien regardé j'ai gtc étant
ici je peux riche peut rien faire mourir
attention à l'enfer
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît regardez là tout va bien
on est sur le lent je roule à 30 et
ancien enfant diriez pas encore
meilleure fiac
je vais faire ça tout est paré
y a pas d'enfant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
quand
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
japanese j'ai eu ma vision
[Applaudissements]
tamedia et la comédienne ce que de la
marque et la cheville elles aussi
formidable bravo à eux
je crois que vous avez purée et la
danoise est vanessa était fabuleuse la
dame blanche au coeur de ma vie j'ai
plus de voix depuis ça fait toujours
mais il ya eu ça il ya eu çà et là
meilleure phrase pour moi de tout le
truc c'est la meuf
c'est une fois fait gênant je crois que
c'est la clim crois que c'est la
meilleure phrase la gâteau proue de
l'histoire des phrases je crois que
c'est la pluie c'était exceptionnel
franchement et à 83
est-ce que vous m'avez insulté bad a
connu au début qu'on avait appris aussi
à pas du tout pas du tout et vous non
pas du tout c'est vrai non non vous
restez c'était rigolo après mais sur le
coup j'ai vraiment eu la peur des
malades mais vraiment il y est également
question d vraiment à me demander de
monter sur elle pour la nourriture et le
rct a gagné sur moi je la porte on
aurait dû mettre maxime gagné avec vous
ici le belge ben bravo en tout cas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]